hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason I o
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied in taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to YouTube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well I will talk about
this meeting and you stay I want to go
on from from here McIntyre says that one
of the mistakes that emotivism makes is
mistaking the meaning of moral language
for its uses so the meaning of oral
language would be what the expression
this actually says saying so if you say
stealing is wrong that's not the same
thing as the use that you might put to
it which is you know maybe making
somebody feel bad who's been caught
stealing they think about when you were
a kid I'm sure all of you did something
wrong and your parents actually without
giving you a sort of explanation just
said that's walk and they said in a
certain tone of voice that conveyed
their their anger or their irritation or
their disgust or whatever right it's an
experience you went through I went
through it many times sometimes about
you know things that were genuinely bad
looking back at it and some some things
about you know very arbitrary I'm not
going to think about people spitting on
the sidewalk she'll chew on your nuts
you know spitting on the sidewalk is a
nice but if you spit on the sidewalk
you're not murdering anybody you know
you're not actually stealing
thing I guess it could be a public
health issue but it's not really that
big of a deal but she conveyed by
talking about she gave the expressionist
certainly use and he use could be
expressing personal preferences or
emotions you can make all sorts of uses
out of things that you say just for one
that actually conveys something about
emotion consider how many different uses
you can make that azz saying to somebody
I love you now what's the meaning of my
love you you actually do love that
person you feel can we define love maybe
maybe not here in this class right now
you know we can teach a whole class buff
what is long you know but let's say that
we actually have some sort of coherent
data all of you have a good idea about
what love looks like what love means oh
so you've experienced it both giving and
taking okay now how do people use that
expression think about the many
different ways yeah okay hmm yeah look
let me let me uh let's just say that
we're talking about a person will come
back to this because that's a that's a
really important point to with respect
to good and love and all these sorts of
things I love cake to my wife for my
birthday mania a special cake that was
chocolate and caramel and you know fly
yeah
I can relate to like and kick Carly
Pines two parts wait so let's talk about
I love you to a person so you could
actually be genuine with it you're
expressing how you actually feel that
person right what are some other God was
like I care about you oh yeah oh now is
love and caring necessarily the same
stuff this is where misunderstandings
arise isn't sometimes I love you when
not subtitles i love you but I'm not in
love with you right and that could mean
I care about you but I'm really not
romantically interested in you i love
you could could be used to shut somebody
up couldn't quit arguing with me i love
you that would be a very different use
wouldn't it then expressing hear your
care for another person you might just
want them to shut up maybe you don't
actually love that maybe you just want
them to knock it off any other uses of i
love you that people could make that are
not necessarily aligned with the more
genuine use yet
necessarily especially be just gotta be
right yeah and now it could mean
something like I desire you but that's
not the same thing as love in a full
sense and so that's a use of a term now
notice the last two ones we looked at
those would be what McIntyre called
manipulative uses of language right
there's a difference between non
manipulative and manipulative uses of
language emotivism as he says breaks
down that distinction because if the
motive ISM is correct all we're doing
when we say things like good bad you
know law hates any any sort of
emotionally morally charged words is
expressing our emotions and trying to
change the emotions of other people
trying to change their behavior to based
on those emotions if you're out you know
Saturday night and somebody says like
I'm falling in love with you and what
they really want is to get you in bed
they're not trying to just you know like
turn on a switch they're actually trying
to influence how you feel about things
they're saying I love you because they
want certain feelings to happen on your
part which will result in sooner or
later the two of you being in the same
place at the same time all right outside
of the bar did you say thinkin maybe
that's not I mean that kind of goes with
it I think this is this really basic
stuff as he has to do with their
everyday lives so there's a lot of
difference between meaning and use and
if a motive ism is actually correct all
we have are these sort of manipulative
uses now McIntyre doesn't think that
emotivism is actually correct why is he
interested in talking about just to like
knock it down and now we're done with a
motive
and we don't worry about it anymore he's
interested in it because he thinks that
it's got its hooks into our culture